il fait bon jour merci d'être en direct
avec nous et leurs seize groupes issus
donc de quoi de formations différentes
appelle justement à une coalition à une
formation populaire politique est-ce que
vous pensez que cet appel va voilà va se
concrétiser ce que finalement c'est un
espoir dans un renouvellement de la
classe politique libanaise actuellement
en fait vous allez poser le vrai
problème parce que depuis la révolution
en fait il n'y a pas eu de formation
d'une véritable alternative politique
donc effectivement le fait qu'ils
certains groupes qui sera 100 pour
proposer une nouvelle offre sur la scène
politique ça peut nécessairement fait
tonner peut-être sans un souffle nouveau
dans la classe politique
maintenant est ce qu'il faut dire c'est
que les groupes qui ont fait cette
conférencière ces groupes que nous
étions des idées en commun
or dans le dans la révolution vous avez
énormément de courant avec différentes
idées donc le courant qui enfin la
coalition qui c'est qui s'est réuni hier
ces conditions un peu de centre-gauche
aux idées laïques et donc en fait c'est
représenter une partie des manifestants
mais pas la totalité
on a surtout l'impression que finalement
ça tape elle illustre un petit peu la
rupture qui est actuellement entre la
classe dirigeante la population
libanaise
oui il ya une rupture parce que
aujourd'hui la situation économique est
catastrophique et du et le gouvernement
fantôme d'être formés donc tout est
bloqué et la population ne sait plus que
de quoi sera fait son avenir
il ya plus ya plus d'emplois il ya plus
de travail à plus de en fait d'activités
économiques les prix ne font
qu'augmenter est en fait la population
ne sait plus à quoi s'en tenir donc
c'est vraiment en fait une situation
désespérée aujourd'hui alors pour que
justement ce projet puisse aboutir
il s'agira également pour ses seize
groupes issus de la société civile peut
être d'unifier un petit peu les rangs
est ce que vous pensez qu'ils vont
réussir
justement a présenté un plan commun
d'action qu'est ce que l'on sait sur
cette formation en fait comme je vous ai
dit cette formation a comme but de
former enfin c'est une coalition de
centre gauche d'une tête dans le but
principal est de la laïcité parce que
l'on voit par exemple l'un des
principaux partis dans cette collection
et le bloc national dont le menton c'est
l'objectif et on sait également que la
laïcité est le projet du président de la
république ni challandes et jusqu'à
maintenant il n'a pas pu l'appliquer
parce qu'il ya des oppositions très
forte
face à lui notamment au niveau des
partis ainsi pour le musulman
j'aimerais que l'on revienne un petit
peu à saad hariri l'actuel premier
ministre libanais qui n'a toujours pas
formé finalement de gouvernement qu'est
ce qui bloque encore en fait il ya
beaucoup de choses qui bloque
saad hariri est en train de rechercher
un soutien à l'étranger que ce soit au
niveau régional l'arabie saoudite les
émirats arabes unis internationale les
etats-unis la france et en même temps il
est le fait d'avoir retardé la formation
du gouvernement
c'était en fait un bras de fer qu'il a
livrée contre le président de la
république qui est derrière cela il ya
un jeu confessionnel parce que en fait
la formation du gouvernement est l'une
des deux dernières prérogatives qui
reste au président de la république et
chrétiens est en fait il a voulu jouer
contre compte cette prérogative est
ainsi rassemblés en fait toute la rue
sunnite qui était en train de le
contester énormément parce que ce qu'il
faut pas oublier c'est que le 17 octobre
là les manifestants quand ils ont quoi
sont ils ont commencé à manifester leur
but principal était la chute du
gouvernement dirigé par saad hariri
et on a vu beaucoup de manifestants ont
manifesté dans les principales villes
subit du pays puisque tripoli et saïda
ce sont deux villes sunnite du pays et
même à beyrouth la population sunnite
est très important c'est là en fait les
communautés la plus la plus nombreuse à
beyrouth et donc dans ces trois villes
où il ya beaucoup de sunnites les
sunnites ont beaucoup contesté saad
hariri est lui en s'en prenant aux
prérogatives du président de république
chrétiens et là il a essayé de souder la
communauté sunnite derrière lui donc
c'est un jeu confessionnel qui a eu lieu
et mais malheureusement c'est au prix de
la du pays parce que le pays est en fait
ne peut pas supporter de rester sans
gouvernement mais il ya aussi un autre
jeu que je voudrais donc je voudrais
parler c'est que il ya un enjeu très
important aujourd'hui qui se joue c'est
l'audit juricomptable qui est l'audit de
la banque centrale mais également des
ministères des administrations publiques
et cet audit juricomptable qui est voulu
par les manifestants et qui évolue
également par le président de la
république ni charmant en fait c'est un
audit dont ne veut pas ni le président
du parlement nabih regret ni le premier
ministre désigné saad hariri mis leurs
alliés walid joumblat leur allié russe
donc il ya ce bras de fer aujourd'hui
qui est livrée donc d'un côté ceux qui
sont pour l'audit et de l'autre côté
ceux qui sont contre l'audit c'est très
important parce que en fait si cet audit
n'est réalisé on pourra détecter qui a
volé qui a fait du détournement fonds
qui s'est enrichie illicitement et en
fait il ya beaucoup de politiciens qui
ont peur que cet audit et lieu et il ya
un jeu entre eux et l'association des
banques et malheureusement la banque
centrale qui est dirigé par riad salamé
vous avez vu beaucoup d'articles sur le
sujet il ya presse française merci
beaucoup en tout cas michel fayyad
d'avoir répondu à nos questions je
rappelle que vous êtes analyste
politique et financier est libanais